so I am Steven Wilkins I'm the director
Milind Center I know that many of you
have been here today to our inaugural
European Studies graduate fellows
Network conference so my fans are really
pleased to host and support this event
which includes students as well as
faculty discussants from 10 different
institutions from throughout the world
and we're particularly pleased to be
including people from five institutions
in the international alliance for
research universities Network and we
hope to do more with the Alliance in the
future and so I know this is ongoing
thank you for coming and we're very glad
to have you
so today I've got the pleasure of
introducing ambassador Melissa piano
[ __ ] do research who is the ambassador
of Montenegro to the United Nations
so academics are very good at one thing
typically they we've been hired to
research something and that doesn't
necessarily mean as anybody an academic
administration knows that we're very
good at other things but the Ambassador
is really an exception to that rule she
had a very distinguished career has had
a very distinguished career in telecom
engineering she has a PhD in that field
she continues even as ambassador to
supervise graduate students in that
field from her perch in the UN but she's
always been a publicly engaged
intellectual active in politics while
she was active in academia and so she's
managed very adroitly to combine both of
those specialties throughout her career
she helped to usher in the Internet age
to Montenegro being president of the
board of the first internet provider in
Montenegro she has also had a position
of Minister of Defense for several years
so it's really a highly unusual career
from both the academic perspective and
from the international policy policy
practitioner perspective and I was
talking with her earlier and she thinks
that the
side helps to be better at the other
that having that academic grounding
enables you to take a certain distance
from the policy side of things to not
get completely invested in that and also
on the other side perhaps thinking about
the broader policy side also helps me to
be a better academic so today she's
going to speak to us on contemporary
security challenges for Europe there is
certainly plenty of them and we're
really delighted to have the ambassador
here to help us navigate that territory
so welcome good afternoon everyone I'm
really glad to be a part of the
conference here and I want to thank of
course for the very kind introduction I
got here this afternoon and where you
could see that I am really someone who
is trying to combine two very I would
say not always very distant
possibilities offered with my academic
background and with my involvement and
public engagements it was probably
possible because I'm coming from
relatively small country where actually
we've got to be very careful about the
resources and the way how we engage
ourselves and that my engagement came as
somehow consequence of all the changes
we did have at the end of 80s when a lot
of people from University and from
academic community thought that we might
help contribute to the changes which
were necessary in our region by our
expertise knowledge and the willingness
to be a part of the changes a lot of
people of course got disappointed on
that way because as you all might
suppose politics is very much different
from what we are doing in academia and
it needs a lot of patience
a lot of percerin's to stay and I've
chosen to stay in a way to be involved
with the things which I perceived to be
important for my country and that's why
I used to call myself a kind of a
project-based politician and that's why
I was always involved in a project that
were much larger than myself for the
country like preserving the peace in
Montenegro when everything started at
the beginning of nineties like making a
distinction in comparison with very bad
politics in our region by fighting for
regaining independence of Montenegro
which we did in 2006 and by working very
hard for getting to the Montenegro
membership in NATO so these were the
projects I thought were very very
important and that's why I got engaged
in that part of the activities so when I
got the invitation to be a part of the
conference here today I thought what
might be the topic of course I could be
talking to you about something I'm
actually very much involved as
ambassador of Montenegro in un and which
is somewhere at the crossroads of my
expertise and my experiences and which
deals with cyber security but then I
thought that maybe we can do that
another time following what is the main
topic of the conference which is going
on today and tomorrow and we decided
that I might give you a kind of overview
of what is the security situation in
Europe nowadays so starting from the
fact that we are all witnessing the fact
that actually the whole world is
changing and the Europe is facing a very
complex and uncertain security
environment
we will all very much agree I believe
that for decades in the last century
20th century actually after the end of
the Second World War
European struck a security generally was
structured around that east-west
conflict which we called Cold War
containing itself disputes both between
and within the two blocks then the fall
of Berlin Wall unleashed these brutal
conflicts related with the outbreak of
Yugoslavia the first place forcing the
principal political security
institutions to adapt to such challenges
once the situation came into the
peaceful phase the main institutions in
charge of them European security
landscape were the ones actually which
we could say OSCE European Union NATO UN
also partially and they mainly focus
from that time on on issues related with
threats on spots which were outside our
particular continent in Afghanistan
Middle East Africa and while that was
certainly very much justified what has
not been foreseen at at that time were
fundamental changes in the international
security environment driven by power
transitions among states as well as
power diffusions from governments to
non-state actors worldwide these
developments have created a kind of
strategic shock resulting in increasing
instability within the whole post Cold
War World Order
they also contributed toward greater
public discontent and increasing
challenges to governance in many
European states but in itself causes
degradation of the whole European
security and introduces disturbing
elements when it comes to the vision of
Europe whole free and at peace in such
circumstance
is a growing demand is articulated in
Europe within European Union at the
first place towards becoming more
capable more coherent and most returned
a global actor in doing so a
comprehensive approach is a key to
tackle this complex multi actor and
multi-dimensional crisis and growing
security threats contemporary and future
ones as the whole world is transforming
in multiple areas at an exponential rate
the international order that Europeans
helped built has come under great
pressure with the increasing competition
between the great powers and new
security threats including terrorism and
cyber attacks as well as climate change
an element we have to take into
consideration while analyzing security
in Europe and elsewhere is the fact that
many of the changes political social
economic environmental are substantially
influenced a driven by the rapid
development of technologies such
confluence of political socio-economic
and technological trends is actually
redefining the security context globally
and in Europe resulting in complexity
uncertainty and even disorder in the
interconnected world geo technology as
positioning of countries in regard to
complex technology environment could be
considered today as a substitute to
geopolitics in the 19th and 20th century
as new technologies will do much more
than just transform science and research
they will determine how we all live and
function and it is quite clear that the
race for technological real leadership
among the world's powers will be an
important part of the global order
transformation those countries that
create can create and implement
cutting-edge technologies while being
able to adapt to those technologies at
the same time we realize enormous
economic and geotechnical benefits
decades to come as the international
competition competition for the
redistribution of power is having the
tendency of intensifying the main
serious breakdown in that sense happened
in 2014 despite all legal conventions
political agreements security
instruments and institutions being in
place the crisis in Ukraine escalated
into a conflict resulting in the illegal
annexation of Crimea and Russia's
intervention in eastern Ukraine this was
the first time after the Second World
War that one country seized another's
territory in Europe more 30 Russia
Russia led towards the increased
unpredictability we are facing mark not
only with Ukraine crisis but also with
trying to influence political processes
and deliberately interference in
elections to cyber attacks on European
companies and systems investing in
modern military equipment including new
intermediate-range missiles which led to
the demise of the INF treaty there is no
doubt that this crisis created new
momentum in working on competition in
political economic and military realm's
Europe has responded in a unique United
and very firm way the European Union has
stood firm in its use of economic
sanctions while NATO has implementing
the largest reinforcement of its
collective defence since the end of the
Cold War demonstrating to Russia the
consequences of violating international
law on arms control and the demise of
the ionic treaty NATO further
demonstrates its strength and unity by
supporting the United States decision to
withdraw from the treaty remaining
committed to effective arms control
disarmament and non-proliferation at the
same time while European Union is extend
regularly the sanctions NATO continues
to combine meaningful dialogue with
credible deterrence and defense with the
aspiration to have a dialogue but the
meaningful one with Russia and to build
more constructive relationship
rebuilding trust where possible in
addition to these security threats from
its East Europe is also facing
challenges from its south borders as
well particularly international
terrorism but also the migration that
increasingly challenges Europe security
and even its solidarity after the big
migration wave in 2015 a lack of
effective policies or even lack of
national intent to provide equal
opportunity to integrate migrants into
society led towards frustration among
both migrants and local population apart
from creating financial and social
strain disposed security concerns as
public discontent and polarization is on
the rise with a significant lack of
trust in governments and institutions
thus new and old populist movements are
gaining more power in Europe having
anti-government and anti-globalization
agenda threatening cohesion and
capabilities of European Union and NATO
as well
still this particular issue has to be
addressed primarily at national levels
and it is encouraging that the recent
elections for European Parliament showed
the certain positive results in that
sense when it comes to European
counter-terrorist efforts the
transplanted partnership plays a crucial
role as through NATO countries have been
engaged in the us-led global coalition
in the fight against Isis liberating
vast territory and millions of people in
Iraq and Syria in Afghanistan the joint
military presence supports the Afghan
security forces so they can create the
condition
for peace at the situation in northern
East Syria remains difficult it has been
agreed among all partners to safeguard
the gains and maintain the commitment to
missions and operations in the region
including NATO Strait training missions
in Iraq and Afghanistan and the process
for finding a political solution to the
crisis in Syria which is led by un with
the evident redistribution of economic
and military power to it towards Asia
notably the rise of China and the pace
of technological change it is one of the
priorities for Europe to consolidate its
position while working more to
understand and respond to such geo
strategic landscape China will soon have
the world's largest economy economic
power alone is not sufficient to define
the global balance of power but the
Quranic strength is the foundation also
for military power China already has the
second largest defense food budget in
the world investing heavily in new
capabilities it increased its presence
from the Arctic to the Balkans and in
cyber space including its major
investments in infrastructure in Europe
it has hundreds of missiles with a range
that would have been prohibited by the
INF treaty China is becoming global
leader in the development of new
technology from
5g to facial recognition and from
quantum computing to gathering vast
amounts of global data that is why it is
important to understand what the scope
of China's influence means for security
of Europe and the whole West climate
change is drawing a great attention as
it impacts all domains shaping also the
security environment in many ways
putting pressure on individuals and
governments nations have to improve
their resilience by addressing
adaptation measures so that effective
governments would be assured including
prevention of new
qualities mitigation of natural
disasters impacts and consequently new
migrations and displacements to legend
understanding civil and military
vulnerabilities to climate disturbances
in the Keith supply and distribution
systems is acquired as a prerequisite
for improving sustained owned and
developed these islands in Europe all
these described dynamics certainly
challenge European security structures
to bring balance ensure their position
and influence keeping its citizens safe
obtaining the required level of security
in Europe definitely will be a long
process and it is up to policy makers to
design and evolved architecture that
will be agreed upon and then implemented
efficiently in that process each of the
security institution has its own role
and it is of the utmost importance to
avoid any competition or overlap between
them that is something which should be
high in our end of European Union at the
first place while a process of closer
cooperation security and defence will be
put in place
EU Member States agreed actually to step
up the European Union's work in this
area and acknowledge the need to enhance
cooperation increase investment and for
more cooperation in developing defense
capabilities through so-called permanent
structured cooperation on security and
defence with the acronym pesco it is
meant to be a treaty based framework
with the legally binding nature of the
commitments undertaken by the
participating member states for the time
being its 23 of them who signed
agreement for this framework actually
the aim is to jointly develop defense
capabilities and make them available for
EU military operations in this manner
the EU s capacity as an international
sea
security actor would be enhanced
contributing to the protection of video
citizens and maximizing actually the
effectiveness of overall defense
pendings and there have been a lot of
discussions if this new EU security
cooperation instrument will we can
already challenge NATO alliance which
has been a bedrock of transatlantic
security for 70 years proved to be the
most successful defensive alliance in
the history representing half of the
world economic might and half of the
world's military mind the dominant agro
argument is that pesco and NATO will
produce significant strategic
divergences on either side of the
Atlantic and ultimately weaken both US
and EU military capabilities against
potential adversaries moreover as the
two main obstacles to further EU
integration in security and defence
continuing political divisions with
regard to the identification of threats
and foreign policy priorities and unions
military weaknesses concerns over
sovereignty trust technical bureaucratic
and financial hurdles and defense
industry issues complicated scenario
however efforts have been made to
explain that these two arrangements
should be seen as complementary to each
other rather than as opposing forces
indeed if implemented well European
defense initiatives such as pesco could
address the precise u.s. ask for a
stronger European pillar within NATO
greater European defence spending would
be welcomed as well
investments in military capabilities and
enhancement of operational readiness and
pesco could be a very positive
instrument from a transplanting
perspective enhancing capabilities and
burden-sharing within the same
in the same context as nature celebrated
it 70 anniversary with the London
meeting the other day that we all were
following and maybe well we haven't been
very much encouraged what we heard and
what we saw I've got to say that what
counts at the end is what has been
agreed and the record wasn't that bad as
the media picture was so first of all it
was announced everything about the
details of large increases in defense
spending proving the rise in awareness
and commitment towards modifying and
enhancing capabilities required for NATO
mission of defence and deterrence so in
2019 defense spending across European
allies and Canada increased in real
terms by four point six percent making
this the fifth consecutive year of
growth and by the end of the next year
those allies will have in Elstad
something like 130 billion more since
2016 based on the latest estimates the
accumulated increase in defense spending
by the end of 2020 for will be something
like 400 billion what is something which
really represent a change we never seen
up to now when it comes to investment is
defence as such and also more allies
meeting the guideline of spending 2% of
GDP for defence and this year it was
nine allies which met the guideline up
from just three allies a year ago so
actually that is something which is very
important when it comes to the outcomes
of the meetings we tried the other day
together with the full commitment of all
the allies when it comes to nature
readiness initiatives where they all
committed to provide all necessary
resources and capabilities to NATO
readiness forces a lot of that were
missing beforehand I remember the time
when I was around the table and when it
was of course after all the crises with
Ukraine started and when we were working
on all these analyzes which showed at
the time and it wasn't long ago or just
three years ago that these NATO
readiness forces actually just called
like that
it was shown for example that for a
force over nature to be just transported
from say Spain to some of the Baltic
countries it would be needed something
like a week or two so readiness just in
the name nowadays in the last three
years allies did made significant
progress and I believe that they shown
on the meeting in London these days with
all this number they provided that it is
something they are really devoted it's a
serious business and they are at the end
very much committing the resources they
are having to our transatlantic alliance
so as we all do know probably we were
having at some time a tendency to ignore
the fact that freedom and security do
not come for free all this what is the
development could be considered as a
very positive news no matter all these
disagreements and differences or
probably some divisions which we are
witnessing over trade energy climate
trade Iran northern Syria I do believe
that nature is such kind of organization
where all these serious discussions
could be led and were actually by
putting on the table even different
positions they could be coming out with
the unity and solidarity when it comes
to the core tasks of the Alliance
and of course having the full picture
around us I do know that as more as we
are informed as more as we are thinking
about these things as more as we are
analyzing it is not that easy to be that
much optimistic when we are looking at
the world and as we are actually
witnessing the emergence of these new
powers economically politically and
militarily it is definitely a time where
shifts happening very fast and the world
is becoming increasingly unpredictable
and interlinked as such so the Ukrainian
crisis has shown us and somehow reopened
issues that we thought that were closed
completely for over on European ground a
fragility of just reckon Salah dated and
reconstructed Western Balkans for
example as well as spreading instability
in the Middle East and North Africa at
all to the volume of uncertainty
influencing European security context as
such so I also would like to use this
opportunity to draw your attention to
the point that the journey of having
Europe whole free and at peace has not
yet been completed there are still young
and fragile democracies in the southern
part of European contact continent which
have through the integration processes
made a political commitment to
contribute in European security and
prosperity at the same time these
countries are also at the frontline of
emerging security threats and challenges
having all this in mind we can actually
make a conclusion that is of the utmost
importance to reinforce comparable
cooperation and joint efforts of NATO
and EU in the first place in continuing
to keep citizens of Europe safe as
potential implications
the ongoing transition in developing
responses to impending risks are better
recognized collaborative adaptation of
European security architecture should be
the way ahead to prevent negative trends
by staying committed to the core values
while NATO should continue to provide
the main framework for collective
defence of the whole euro-atlantic
region by that kind of statement I would
like to finish this part and I've got to
thank you and of course ask you for
whatever your interests might be in this
issue as I am more than willing to have
a discussion with you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh thank you for brilliant presentation
was really interesting my name is
Maurice nee Guevara I'm a postdoc fellow
at Johns Hopkins University and I work
on the European Union and Russia
unfortunate if impact on it these days I
have two questions so first of all you
were talking about cooperation and
strengthening of NIDA
which are quite remarkable and
commendable could you please comment on
the recent actions and statements of the
French president Macomb about who worked
the EU expansion into the Balkans and of
course the famous native brain death
comment and the second one and I
apologize for that maybe basic question
if you could clarify the necessity for
independent EU initiatives like Pasco
right independent of NATO what are they
achieving that nega cannot why why they
need it thank you
well I expected the question about the
brain-dead NATO which has provoked a lot
of reactions and I would say startled a
lot of people because no one expected
something like that we have seen that it
was on the table at the latest NATO
meeting in London as well and the
president McCrone was put in a position
to explain what he actually meant what I
do believe is that he wanted to give a
kind of a new moment to mean what is
adaptation of NATO to the contemporarily
threats and challenges so of course is
in every organization especially those
multilateral once there is always a need
to go forward and to actually adapt to
the world as we said which is so quickly
changing and why NATO was so successful
is this indeed 70 years I mean NATO was
the one who ensured peace in Europe
after the Second World War
that was the Alliance together with of
course European Union that helped in
putting aside all the divergences and
all the things horrible things that we
are happening in to war
world wars in Europe of course the
second one being dressed a kind of a
second act of the first one which hasn't
been completed actually so from that
point I do believe that we should be
thinking about his position as a call
for further adaptation and for further
frank discussions what and how should be
done so from that point as I said to you
already
before Ukraine crisis nature was a kind
of of course the link with the spots we
were outside Europe as it is very
important to have the stability on East
Eastern on its southern flank or on its
northern flank as well so these were the
priorities but when Ukraine happened it
was obvious that everyone was a little
bit too much relaxed expecting that
never something like that could happen
and NATO wrapped it very quickly so from
that point I do believe that even now
when present McCrone is calling for this
kind of discussions it might be only
something very good for NATO because we
already did have a result of that and
the result is that the leaders agreed to
have a kind of high-level panel which
will be chaired by the secretary-general
mr. Stoltenberg and where actually they
will be having working debates on what
next should be done so that NATO would
be ready for all the challenges in front
of us as globally I mean another thing
where it is showed how NATO is now
raised able to respond very quickly is
the fact that due to all developments we
had in the last five years the number of
operational domains changed so just a
couple of years ago it was land sea and
the air nowadays we got cyber and the
newly one we've got space so that all
means how wealth all these things were
recognized there and how quickly NATO is
able to adapt its missions to what might
be true
returning peace and security when it
comes to integration of course and the
further enlargement towards Western
Balkans which the enlargement as such
has proved in the last 30 years is the
most efficient instrument for
consolidating new democracies especially
those who were part of the Warsaw Pact
and then those who were part of the
ex-yugoslavia and who went through all
these atrocities we went through so of
course that the Regent wasn't very much
satisfied or wasn't satisfied at all
with this kind of comments but on the
other side I also perceived that present
McCrone wanted to put forward the fact
that everything what was happening
especially after 2015 and after all
these crises with migration and
everything and populist movements which
raisin in Europe they've got to
consolidate themselves so to find the
unique holes which will be much more
stronger in that sense I do believe that
the new European Commission and the new
president which I had a privilege to
work with while she was Minister of
Defense in Germany will be very
efficient in proving and showing showing
how important it is to go further with
the enlargement in a way of course which
will be consolidated the process we have
nothing against that what we do need is
international community the first place
European Union be present in the region
of Western Balkans for example just to
ensure that these countries are
continuing to develop on the way which
is related with building democracy
strengthening rule of law of freedom of
media and the other values which are
related with the real democratic
societies
yeah of course so that's what I tried to
explain there was a lot of discussions
about that whether pesco is something
which could be considered as competition
to nature and whether it came at some
point when we did have from this part of
Atlantic some kind of statements which
were putting into consideration the
efficiency of efficiency of NATO you do
remember some statements saying about
NATO becoming obsolete and things like
that so we were all actually very
curious whether that might be response
to this kind of position from the United
States but then actually European states
made it clear they just wanted red to
have it as a kind of a complementary to
NATO and at the first place I would say
to ensure that on the spots where NATO
as a transatlantic alliance is not
having priorities they could go for
their priorities and they very well
explained that we already did have a
couple of places where it was
demonstrated like Africa like Mali and
what is going on that was the kind of
prayer priority for European countries
but not for the NATO is a such so they
want to have capabilities in that sense
and what they want to do is of course to
further on develop their defence
industry that is something which is from
their point of view also important and I
do believe that that is important then
if it's put into the function of course
of the transatlantic alliance when it's
necessary so from that point I believe
that with the majority of those
countries which signed already pesco
there is not that intention to go some
other way
yes thank you ambassador do you think
that the EU would would need a defense
treaty with UK after brexit knowing that
say Sweden and Austria and Ireland are
not part of NATO but you do know that
inator is having with them a very strong
cooperation and special agreements which
are in place when it comes to grexit I
got to say that we are all aware that
it's a kind of developments we tree is
very very difficult to see how it will
be ended in a sense to go forward of
course but what the deal would be is
something I think no one still knows so
when it comes to NATO what we could hear
yes is that UK will remain of course
completely committed and from that point
it's one of the most important allies
and definitely a part of the deal with
the European Union will have something
to do with the defense no one still
knows watch because we did have as a
priority or day did have as a priority
all these things which are related with
social economical things three things
and being very much on the east knowing
the day.i nature also from that point
still a way to go
hi my name is runnable I'm a second year
masters student here so my question is
about Montenegrin policy in an age of
great power competition so as you had
pointed out in your excellent
presentation that montenay sort of the
rice of China and other Asian countries
have interesting implications for
European countries at the same time for
Montenegro in particular to become part
of the EU it had need to develop in its
infrastructure but the type of countries
that are sort of willing to lend money a
china included for instance the last
time the big project happened in 2016
Montenegro took a debt equal to roughly
one-fifth of the country's GDP for that
year and it had rather negative
implications for it some debt
sustainability but going forward um how
do you view Montenegro is role in
balancing the interest of the United
States China and the European Union
once we regained our independence he I
will remind you that Montenegro in 19th
century was just one of the first 47
recognized countries on the Berlin
Congress and that's and then we lost our
independence II after the first world
war and that's why I'm always insisting
that in 2006 we regained our
independence II so at that point we
clearly put our priorities forward with
our NATO membership in the EU membership
and that is something which is not at
stake at any point and I've got to say
that when it comes to EU integrations
then there is a consensus in the country
when it comes to NATO there are
divergences but the gain majority is
there where it is and there is simply no
circumstances under which that could be
put in question of course one of the
priorities for the government and for
the state as such was to build up when
it comes to infrastructure Montenegro is
one of the top rising touristic
destinations in the world and we are
very proud of that but of course we
don't know how to sustain
this kind of development trend we do
need real infrastructure we are very
proud of the fact when it comes to I
cities when it comes to telecom and
information infrastructure we are one of
the leaders not only in the region but
in Europe as well we did that on time
and we that did that really with very
much of involvement of all the
professionals and the government led
that way but when it comes to the
physical infrastructure there are issues
and one of the very important issues the
roads in the highways there of course we
would prefer to have the partners which
would be our natural partners as I would
say from the west from the Europe from
the United States but unfortunately a
lack of inter interest of investors from
the West opened space for some others
it's all decided in open international
public tenders and what we've got at a
time as many of the countries in the
region and in Europe as well was an
offer from China for the part of our
highway which as you said is a very
challenging one from the point of engage
resources following the fact that
configuration of the terrain is
Montenegro in that part from the south
to the north is very challenging
it's very mountainous and we are at the
moment building just something like 43
kilometers of that highway which will
cost modern billion dollars because it's
all via drugs tunnels bridges there is
nothing flat there and it was Chinese
who are building that and still building
that they should finish that by the end
of the next year but that is something
which is showing how the lack of
presence and lack of interests of our
natural partners is opening the space
for some others
I mean you can't say that okay now there
is no one from there we'll stop all our
development
it wouldn't be responsible action so
from that point we are advocating the
necessity of integrations of the
presence of our allies and partners in
the region because if they are not
present then everything will be open for
some others Montenegro specifically is
having a very bad experience which
everything which happened a couple of
years ago when we were working on our
NATO membership you do know that in them
in that time after the Ukraine crisis
and everything when we faced more
assertive Russia that one of the spots
where Russia was showing the interest to
fill the gaps or just to undermine
European Union or NATO was Montenegro
and we did have that fortunately
unsuccessful coup d'etat which was
unsuccessful I was there at the time I
firmly believe because of the fact that
on the way to integrate to NATO we build
up our capabilities so good that even
the small country we were able to give
the right responses and to prevent any
kind of bad consequences so having our
own experience with everything which
means this information hackers different
propaganda we were able to show to other
allies even in NATO what we were talking
about because a lot of them didn't
understand beforehand because they
didn't expect
they just didn't foresee where it could
be going further on so from that point I
believe that we will be working further
on together with the others to show to
our partners how
important it is to be in that part of
the world thank you very much master and
I have two very quick questions one is
what do you see as the role of India in
in a turn in the European project
politically and economically and
militarily and second is whether you see
that the growing influence of Russia and
China in filling in some of the vacuum
that us-led in Institute's let's call it
broadly initiatives or engagements in
throughout Eurasia do you see that as a
context and if that is so then it's not
a simply a story of a lack of lack of
interest from the West invest in certain
regions is actually there are social
transformations and changes and Wars
that leave there's this tiny vacuum and
if that is so then us actions in Eurasia
leaves room for Russian Chinese
influence leaving in a a legacy and a an
aftermath for European countries and so
do you see there be a more robust role
for European countries in terms of
decision makings in in before the these
engagements from the US so so that that
is it does NATO should shoot NATO have a
more robust presence in terms of
collaborating with the u.s. in thinking
long terms of Eurasian security and
maybe exercising more prudence in these
cases thank you so fast with the
resources which are considerable and I
do believe that on a bilateral level
each of the countries including my own
are trying to get into closer
cooperation
really resources Audrey there and they
are size when it comes to something
structured then India is of course a
partner of nature as well for some of
these spots we mentioned before which
what is I would say a kind of advantage
when we are talking about India is that
of course being the biggest democracy in
the world no one is doubtful when it
comes to the goals and ways how they are
providing democracy for their own
citizens so that is a kind of big
guarantee when you come into the
relations with India and it is of course
perceived as a great partner in that
part of the world what is not the case
with the other big power from Asia and
you probably have seen as well that on
this meeting we had the other day in
London that NATO in all countries agreed
on the declaration where they mentioned
China for the first time so that is
actually the real demonstration on what
is perceived as something that NATO
should be having an eye on so for the
time being is just that apart from
everything which is going on in
technology and 5g and of course security
threats which are related with that and
where are all NATO countries completely
on the same line on the other side of
course what nature did and the European
Union in the first place nature it's a
defensive alliance so in all this what
is happening its defence and the other
component is deterrence so what has been
decided is to be more active in
deterrence hoping that it will help in
keeping the peace on European and
American continent is a search so when
you see the actions first authorities
that enhance presence which is at the
borders
you will see that actually it is about
deterrence in the first place and for
the time being it is sending the right
messages and of course having in mind
that capability of the quick adaptation
we do hope that it will be no use for
that but still if it is necessary then
there are things in place as this is
these new forces for the quick responses
well so actually I would say that in the
last four years nature did much more
than in previous maybe 25 which is an
assurance for all of us I believe thank
you so much we're actually going to wrap
up now there's a reception upstairs and
you're welcome to speak with the
ambassador up there as well thank you
for coming and please thank me I mean
yeah thank you ambassador
[Applause]
[Music]